[Music]
these are German police officers raiding
mosques and organizations in Berlin
these places are suspected of links to a
Shiite Muslim called Hezbollah Arabic
for party of God it happened right after
the government declared Hezbollah a
terror
following in the footsteps of many
others including the UK Saudi Arabia and
the United States Hezbollah was formed
some 40 years ago in this tiny Middle
Eastern country it has since expanded
its reach to almost every continent on
the planet its operations have often
been violent but the group's activities
are multifaceted it's quite striking
quite interesting how difficult it seems
to be for political analysts political
scientists the think tankers in the
world media understand POTUS Bala is so
what exactly is Hezbollah and why has
its reach now spread so far from where
it began let us unpack that for you
[Music]
part of the reason why Hezbollah is so
difficult to pin down is that it's an
organization that spans many categories
so Hezbollah is a political party it is
a social welfare organization it has
civilian organizations it is a standing
militia larger better funded better
armed than the Lebanese Armed Forces and
it is also a terrorist organization that
engages in acts of terrorism at home in
Lebanon and abroad as well as a
transnational criminal organization it
considers itself a at the same time a
state and a non-state actor it was born
in an environment where the state was
absent a weak being a hybrid
organization has advantages for
Hezbollah the many hats it wears are all
a means to one end
spreading what it calls an ideology of
resistance as far and as wide as
possible it's based on the idea that has
Bala leads the resistant against a
fragment resistance against oppression
against the stronger powers in the
region but also in a global level that's
why it's always had a very strong aunt
is really of course entry zionist but
also entry of anti-american discourse
because it positioned itself as the
defender of those that no one takes care
of that are suffering from the
oppression of colonial imperialist or
whatever powers of the region this is
the main narrative with office Paula
emphasis and it's his own death today
this is just one but a big factor in
Hezbollah's popularity its followers see
the group standing up for the
disempowered
just take a listen to what some of its
supporters say dominate my shovel my
moon severely armored illegal
America was odious I hid mineral yellow
when your mala hello who is a hidden
hate me
sayyidina muhammad who say the nasara
who say it is similarly under its leader
Hassan Nasrallah Hezbollah has gained
enduring popularity reflected in its
election results it has won seats in
every parliament since 1992 and has
participated in government's since 2005
there are entire parts of the country
believed to be dominated by them and
while it also has many detractors in
Lebanon here's a glimpse of the number
of people Hezbollah can mobilize for its
rallies
ideology matters in the Middle East
today regardless of what we tell you
ideology is still a factor it's not the
only factor and it's not probably not
even the most important factor but it is
important and in the case of Hezbollah
it really makes a difference this
popularity often runs deep in Lebanese
communities abroad Hezbollah
sympathizers include entrepreneurs and
businessmen funnel money to the group
back in Lebanon
due to the political instability in the
country but also historically for a long
time Lebanese have migrated across the
world and we find a lot of very
successful shia lebanese businesspeople
in Australia in West Africa in South
America in Europe and in the United
States and of course there are certain
royalties
[Music]
so as well as is receiving support from
donations but also from the business
activities informal let's say illegal
also sometimes business activities that
are that are conducted in order to fund
the organization yet the diaspora is
only one part of the group's global
reach and that brings us to another key
thing to know about Hezbollah its
intimate relationship with Iran don't
take our word for it this is what
Hezbollah's leader had to say about it
knocking al maxi Oh freedom can hey
civil alum color se la havas la jolla
non-us a fair few Saudi viola ronon
teyla na na hey ha dejado sabes muazzin
at hezbollah wanna share toma sorrowful
who act low syllables levels away we who
men azumarill Islamiyah fira
[Music]
and this is how Hezbollah supporters
received Iran's then President Mahmoud
Ahmadinejad in a visit to Lebanon Walla
and Iran have a very intimate
relationship it is ideological without
Iran there would certainly be no
Hezbollah in 1979 there was a turning
point in Iran that set the stage for
this alliance a revolution in the
country saw Iran's monarchy overthrown
and an Islamic Republic established
instead soon afterwards
Hezbollah emerged in Lebanon as one of
the many factions fighting in the
country's long-running civil war it was
formed as a militia belonging to the
Shiite sect of Islam Iran itself a
Shiite majority country was there at the
very beginning and became a natural ally
and supporter to Hezbollah
when Hezbollah was first being formed in
Lebanon out of the motley crew of
various Shia militant organizations
Quran right after the Revolution sent
some 1,500 officers to the Bekaa Valley
to train these fighters and coalesced
them into what became known as Hezbollah
the party of God that training included
importantly not only kind of military
training and also ideological training
not only religious but specifically
ideological a commitment to the idea of
exporting the Iranian Revolution which
was never intended to stop at the
borders of Iran and right from the
beginning Hezbollah and Iran started
acting together in the international
arena Hezbollah carried out multiple
attacks in places like Argentina the UK
and even Lebanon itself
Hezbollah is the sharp end of the spear
that Iran is able to deploy especially
when it wants to do something with
reasonable deniability
we know from US court proceedings in
federal court that we know specifically
the one Hezbollah started carrying out
attacks targeting Western interests
worth this happened not at Hezbollah
zone bad idea but it has to be Ron Iran
has also used this relationship to gain
leverage over Israel a country it has
long about to destroy despite widespread
condemnation in 2006 after capturing two
Israeli soldiers Hezbollah was involved
in a month-long world with Israel that
left many civilians dead on both sides
Iran supplied has below with arms used
in the conflict Iran may not be a
borderline state with Israel by virtue
of having Hezbollah there effectively a
borderline statement Israel Hezbollah
has also been seen playing a role in
major conflicts and sometimes acting as
a proxy for Iran against its enemies
like Saudi Arabia
[Applause]
is Bella's engaging activity all over
the world
sometimes at its own behest and
sometimes on behalf of Iran and most
frequently a combination of the two
Hezbollah is a prototype and at the same
time a very special case of Iran trying
to gain strategic depth in the Middle's
take this example after the onset of the
conflict in Syria in 2011 Hezbollah
eventually sent troops to fight on the
side of the Assad regime
Hezbollah's activity in Iraq and in
Yemen its support to militants in rain
this has much more to do with
Hezbollah's role in Iran's shadow war
with its adversaries whether it's with
the West or other Sunni countries in the
region and that hezbollah has a
prominent role - plenty of those fights
over the past few years has Hezbollah
really become much more involved as a
regional actor and I do think that this
has changed the nature of Hezbollah
moving forward it's unlikely to go back
to being just an actor in Lebanon only
targeting Israel for carrying out
terrorist attacks around the world out
of its own and Iran's interest it's now
also a regional fighting force thanks
for watching this edition of unpacked
there's still so much more we could
explain about Hezbollah whether it's the
size of its military wing other reasons
for its popularity and Lebanon and
abroad and the implications of
designating it a terror organization if
you have any more questions about the
group or about anything that we've
covered in this video let us know in the
comments section and we'll get back to
you